Have you ever wanted to improve
your community or help
your local government become
more connected?
With the power of the Google
Places API, you can.
We're inviting developers,
designers, and other
tech-savvy individuals to enter
our Google Places API
Developer Challenge and
build an app to
make something better.
You can make your community
healthier by connecting people
with places to exercise or help
your local government
collect traffic data to
prevent accidents.
Your app can be on
any platform, for
desktop, or for mobile.
All that's required is that you
use the Google Places API,
and the rest is up to you.
The best entry wins a VIP trip
to Google I/O in 2013.
Enter now at developers.googl
e.com/challenge.